大丈夫、ここでストヤン私は決してvlogしませんが、
私は今ブラウンジャパンから連れてきた私の親友のクリスと一緒にい
ます。
あなたはマスクであなたに会いました大丈夫
あなたは私にこの話
が最高だと言わなかったので私
はここで灰の人としてこれで働いていましたなぜ私たち
は暖炉の隣に立っているのですか
英国に戻った城で大丈夫、それは
アメリカの億万長者が
来ると言うイーロン・マスクの誕生日でした、そしてこれは何年も
前のことでしたマイクは10年前か
何かであるに違いありませんそしてイーロン・マスクは特に英国ではそれほど有名ではなかったと言います
その後
、モデルが本格化したときのテスラの始まりのように、
基本はまだ初期の頃だったと思います。
ええ、
私はビジネスと起業家精神に夢中になっていたので、私は彼を知っていました。
私は彼が基本的にアイアンであるアイアンマンであることを知っていました
彼はジョン・
ファブローと友達で、後輩を奪ったので、彼はすでにそうだったのですが、私たち
が現れたので、彼は彼のすべて
の友達やシリコンバレーと同じよう
に私が働いていた城に来ました。
彼が私を通り過ぎたときにホールに立っていたのを覚えている
ので、うわーを見て、夜が明けると、
クリス
の誰かがエロン・ムスクにバースデーケーキを渡さなければならないようです。
たまたまエリムスクにバースデーケーキをあげるロケット
の形をした大きなバースデーケーキのようです
カメラを下に引い
て、手でロケットを見てみてください
まるでロケットの形をした
バースデーケーキのようで、お誕生日おめでとうミスターを連れて行かなければなりません
。 モスクワのケーキダウン
彼らは私があなたの邪悪なマストカメラを正しく倒したと想像します
ああカメラそしてそれから
ケーキは彼の顔に打ち砕かれ彼を殺し
ました
私が
ElonMuskを殺さないことで、彼のRakeshバースデーケーキに固執することで、
実際に彼のベース
会社を救うことができます
。ElonMuskを誤って殺さ
ないことで、
そうです。
彼が世界を歩き回って、彼がしている
すべての素晴らしいことをしているのを見て、
よく考えているのを疑う私は彼にこれほど近くに
いて、ロケットの形をしたバースデーケーキを彼に与えました
彼の伝記はそれほど昔ではありませんでした
あなたがそうしていたらそこにあったでしょうええええええ私
は仕事1についてひどいことをしたので
私は誤っ
て花嫁のドレスラムミントソース全体にビネガーソースをひっくり返しました eは
花嫁のドレス全体に明るい緑色のミントソースがあり、それがあったドレスを台無しにしました。
彼女が知っている間、私はそれ
を彼女とテーブル全体に100人
注ぎました。 数学だけだった